Звісно, в мене є відчуття гордості, тому що мій молодший брат робить те,
чого не робить багато інших чоловіків.
Мене звати Сандра. Я сестра начальника штаба та першого заступника командира
полку "Азов" Кротевича Богдана. І зараз я розповім про свого брата.
Командний склад виходив останнім. І в кращому разі, командний склад
так і повернеться останнім. А перед ними дуже багато хлопців.
Це робота нашої держави. Вони давали їм гарантії. Вони їм обіцяли.
Вони їм дали наказ скласти зброю і вийти. Вони виконали перший наказ
- захищати Маріуполь до останнього. Вони захищали Маріуполь до останнього….
Їм дали наказ вийти - вони взяли й вийшли… І незрозуміло, куди вийшли….
У мене з 20-го травня від командного складу взагалі немає ані слова:
де вони, що вони. Я, наприклад, не знаю точно.
Я не знаю, як нам так доносили інформацію. Жодного слова в засобах масової інформації
не було про те, яка ситуація в Маріуполі. Ми всі дивилися тільки на Київ, Київську область…
Навіть хлопці, воюючи там, у Маріуполі, мені писав щодня брат: "Що там в Києві?"
Тобто їх це більше цікавило. І своїм хлопцям вони передавали:
головне, щоб витримав Київ і Харків. Мовляв, ви на нас не дивіться,
ми тут якось будемо триматися, головне, врятуйте і захистіть Київ, Харків.
А от 12 березня я дізналася всю правду, що вони в кільці, і що, в принципі,
у них дуже погана ситуація.
Вони всі знали, що буде повномасштабна війна. Це Росія.
Вони (росіяни) вже пішли. Вони не залишаться на своїх позиціях.
Вони не віддадуть ті території, які вони вже забрали. Вони вже забрали Крим,
вже забрали Донецьк з Луганськом, вони не віддадуть ці території.
Вони (азовці) планували всі вісім років. Що вони будуть робити, як їм діяти далі.
Тому, звісно, і провізію вони планували на багато місяців вперед,
і медикаменти вони планували на багато місяців вперед.
Але вони ж не думали, що їм доведеться себе кормити, цивільним постійно
поставляти продукцію і суміжні підрозділи забезпечувати медикаментами,
провізією, водою, так далі.
Чесно скажу я, скільки разів у нього не питала, що з харчами, з водою.
Він мені ставив питання: "Це тебе стосується? Тебе це не стосується.
Навіщо ти питаєш?" Він просто така людина. Він мені сказав одне-єдине:
Нам би БК - бойовий комплект. Ми там будемо стояти вічність.
Оце мені він сказав. Все.
Він з 2014-го, з самого початку, тобто, коли почалися активні бойові дії,
йому було двадцять років. Саме Майдан закінчився. Він думав піти в батальйон,
тоді був "Донбас" або "Азов". Але він сказав, що для нього "Азов" - це був дуже правильний вибір.
Він контужений ще з 2014 року, коли вони відбивали Широкине, Павлопіль,
Гранітне і так далі. Тоді були гради. Тоді було дуже страшно.
Він розповідав дуже страшні історії. Одна з них - як він лежав у ямі,
були гради, насипали… Він розповідав про те, що таке відчуття,
що поки в тебе снаряд від граду не попаде, то він не перестане стріляти.
З ним дуже важко розмовляти, тому що він не любить розповідати
всі ці військові якісь моменти, хвилювати. Він такий. У нього так:
"Я військовий, я цим займаюся ". Звідки у нього це з'явилося, що ти військовий?
Ти взагалі ніколи навіть не був на військовій кафедрі.
Ти не мав жодного відношення ніколи до військової справи.
Але у 20 років просто взяв і пішов.
Ну, у нього характер...  Як на мене, справжнього чоловіка.
Мені подобається його характер. Не тому, що він мій брат.
Тому що я вважаю, що чоловік має бути таким, як він - принциповий, цілеспрямований.
У деяких речах дуже дотошний. Він дуже любить читати серйозні книжки.
Тобто він, мабуть, на військову тематику за ці роки перечитав дуже багато книжок.
Навіть я знаю, що багато операцій, які він планував, щось було взято так само з історичних подій.
Ми з Криму, у нас ніколи це не виховували. У мене батько з Донецька,
мама з Сумської області, тому там солянка. Ніколи ніхто в житті
не ходив у вишиванках, не святкував якісь українські свята.
Ніхто нікого ніколи не виховував, що ми українці, що маємо так бути.
Воно само вийшло так.
Доводиться весь час нагадувати. Що це хлопці, які 86 днів захищали нашу державу.
Що основна кількість військових Росії й техніки була сконцентрована
саме на Маріуполі, саме на "Азовсталі" потім.
І саме "Азовсталь" отримала найбільше, ніж хтось інший отримав.
Тому весь час про це доводиться нагадувати.
У мене немає вибору. Просто якщо я не буду триматися, то я не зможу йому допомогти.
Я морально вже виснажена, тому що для мене це, скажімо так,
життя стало на паузу дев'ять років тому, коли він пішов.
А з 24 лютого, то взагалі я забула, що таке життя.
Тому що мені немає коли про це думати. Я просто хочу повернути брата.
Щоб він повернувся до нормального, звичайного життя.
Такого, яке в нього було до 2014-го року.
Все, мені в принципі, більше нічого не потрібно…